joining me this week is an author and
screenwriter who has written such novels
as true crime and don't say a word and
his host of the Andrew Clavin show right
here on the YouTube
Adric Lathan welcome to the Reuben
report thank you kindly good the beer
what do you consider yourself first you
consider yourself an author or a
screenwriter or or now a youtuber or a
commentator which then either sound
dirty to you which which one first
but you know I always all I ever wanted
to be was a novelist that was my only
ambition and I was I was dragged into
movie writing against my will and so
I've always just thought of myself as a
novelist now I've kind of broadened it
out because I'm writing a lot of
nonfiction to an author I call myself a
man of letters I think I I am strangely
find myself in front of a camera and
have not yet become comfortable with it
because I spent most of my life in a
room by myself
yeah so you're freaking out right now
you're under the care your camera line
oh I got such a froth at the mouth and
things like that it no you know it's
funny I'm gettin used to it I've gotten
used to it I think of myself as a person
who writes and then goes on camera
sometimes and reads what I what I write
yeah so for somebody that write and that
you've seen your your books turn into
films and things like that how much of
the process do you fear giving up at
some point you know when it's one thing
when you're writing something and now
you do it on YouTube directly for some
of the package pieces you've done or
just sharing your thoughts as you are
this isn't you didn't pre write it yeah
I I didn't do it yeah nervous about that
yeah
all right you never know what's gonna
happen but when you've seen your words
turn into other things what's it like
giving up that power I always think that
must be incredibly different well
there's two there's two things I mean
when you give a book over to the movie
people if you don't just kiss it goodbye
they'll drive you insane
you know because they're not going to
make this and in some ways they
shouldn't they should get at the essence
of your book without really because it's
a different art form they should do the
the narrative the way the movie demands
the narrative be done but you really
have to let it go and it can be very
very painful I mean there's a moment in
true crime that Clint Eastwood made
where the central moment in the book is
that
Porter saying you know I don't care
about right or wrong I don't care about
Jesus I don't care about anything all I
care about the things that happen you
know that's that's great and that's the
central moment in the book and it's in
the movie and he says and all I care
about is I have a nose for news yeah all
all yeah like pluck this arrow for my
heart yeah mostly I'm pretty good at it
I always think of the great crime writer
James M Cain
they made Double Indemnity in The
Postman Always Rings Twice and somebody
said how do you feel about what
Hollywood did to your books and he said
Hollywood did nothing to my books
they're right over there on the Shelf
you know and I try to keep that attitude
what I do have a hard time with is I
have our time going in front of a camera
and expressing my opinion and knowing I
might get something wrong yeah because
when you write I write and I rewrite and
I rewrite again and I very rarely make
mistakes and published material at all
occasionally on a fast blog I have a
list of that question and each one more
confusing and double worded than the
next but there's so much that I want to
get into with you because you are a
conservative is that fair to say yes it
is you're a conservative now we're
taping this I want everyone to
understand we're taping this before the
election is going to be aired a little
bit after the election just because
where everyone knows we're doing our
home studio thing so we're just getting
a little ahead of ourselves in content
and you're being good enough to play
along with us it's the magic of
television or the internet I suppose so
so we're not going to talk about the
minutiae of the election per se but I
just want to talk about sort of the
broad philosophical things that have
happened in the country for the past
year so for you as a conservative again
we don't know if Trump's a president or
not right now or Clinton or whoever how
did you feel the conservative movement
fared during the election well I I felt
that I lost this election when Donald
Trump was nominated and I decided that I
was going to let myself go through the
process the grieving process and let it
go at that moment because there was no
one running who represented anything
that I believed which is mostly what I
believe in is personal liberty I believe
that you were made to be free that that
is the point purpose of your life
however you know you put are you define
your own way and do what what it is that
you were prompted by yourself to do
without obviously running over my foot
as you do it right there's nobody there
was nobody running after Trump was
nominated who agreed who believed in
that point of view plus there was nobody
running who met for me the minimum
standard of honesty of lack of
corruption because corruption it really
is a worm in the political body it
really does destroy almost more than bad
ideas bad ideas destroy things but
corruption can destroy even when you
have good ideas and so there was no good
outcome for me and I that's something
that happened look it that's something
that happens in the democracy I can't
always win
there are freedom is always somebody
once said this I freedom is always a
minority point of view what people think
that they want to be free but what they
really want us to be free to tell you
what to do they want to be free to do
what they want to do but you have to do
what they want to do as well right and
so you're always kind of looking for a
coalition and that Coalition fell apart
now
the proudest thing I can say and it's a
really sad thing to say is that the
Republicans nominated a corrupt leftist
authoritarian because our machine fell
apart the Democrats nominated a corrupt
authoritarian leftist because their
machine worked perfectly
that's a we did by accident what they do
on purpose which is fitting because
we're the stupid party and they're the
evil party and so that was very will
unfurl some attack so who would have
been the right person was there somebody
when you look at all these guys was
there someone that you said this is a
conservative that I think is basically
principle is probably corrupt enough to
survive right because you have to have
some level of corruption what was there
someone that you thought or was it maybe
somebody that didn't get involved in the
first I'm a big believer in the biblical
preset but not your faith in Princes I
never looked to these guys to save me I
don't think anybody's gonna make America
great again I don't think anybody's
going to make a stronger together
none of that yeah so I'm I'm pretty
going you know I thought like I like
Marco Rubio because he would move the
party ten yards to the right and I
always think of it that way so you're
just trying to make a gain you're not
gonna win everything you just want to
make a game Ted Cruz basically you know
he was a little far to the right on the
social issues for me but but basically
he believed in terms of government
everything I believed especially when he
started talking about dismantling the
bureaucracy that really made my heart go
pit-a-pat that's that's not a wonky
thing that I love right that is a
conservative most I prefer like how does
a conservative like you take a guy like
Ted Cruz where you say I like the
individual liberty stuff the
Constitution stuff and then for as you
said the social stuff it doesn't even
logically make sense to me something
like a marriage or certainly medicinal
marijuana but I would argue legalization
altogether if these guys want limited
government and the government out of
your personal life what is the
intellectual trapeze that he's dancing
through to give him his answer or is it
just political pandering no no I don't
think that's fair on in Cruz's case the
the point of view is this that in order
for personal liberty to survive certain
behaviors have to be in place so
marriage foundational tradition you know
it's traditionally foundation of a free
society because it creates a
self-governing unit it creates the
family the father the mother the
children and they govern themselves and
therefore they don't have to be covered
governed by other people you know you
have this tremendous problem with out of
wedlock births and all this and so that
that becomes part of the idea of the
sort of three stools of conservatism I
believe that to always err toward
freedom and solve the problem down the
road you know I believe I believe this
all my life I mean I you know I always
said during the gay marriage
controversies I don't like the way it
was settled I'm very much against the
Supreme Court decision that's very
different we can we do that I protect we
can do like that but but I would tell
conservatives there's no shame in losing
when you're right but we're wrong about
gays they should be you know government
the control that can control who you
sleep with and who you love is a
government that is way way way too
strong it's not a little too strong it
is way too strong for anything that
resembles constitutional conservatism
did you feel that that bad notion did
that take root with some of your
conservative friends it was it was a
dividing line almost exactly somewhere
on the age of 60 that I you know when I
would say that at young people's
gatherings everybody would applaud
because at this point for young people
being gays looking left handed they
don't care they could care less you know
and for me it was you know it was it's
natural to me to leave people alone it's
kind of my natural point of view it's
very frustrating to me I have to tell
you I have been a both a personal and
political friend to gay people since I
was young and now I'm old so we're
talking about back in the 70s right
there before it was yet or it was really
cool that anti-gay without an uncle
there are people walking around this
very day who would not come back to my
apartment because they met gay people
there who I'm sure certain are wearing
like the rainbow thing it's all about
brave they are for doing you know yeah
so that that's a little frustrating but
no I mean I think I think that always
when you look back at conservatives
through history they can always connect
the dots it's part of their nature to
connect the dots to a disaster
so if we let women vote disaster if we
let Roman Catholics vote mainland you
know it's a disaster and I always think
you know what maybe but solve the
problem down the road always err on the
side of freedom and and the only thing
that confuses the social issues for me
is the issue of abortion and I find it
insanely offensive that the issue of say
gay marriage who you can love and who
you can live with should be confused
with the issue of saving the life of the
one person in a room who has no vote
where a voice you know and that those
who are the so somehow the social issues
I find that tremendously confused and
offensive but that's there anyway that's
what I think Ted Cruz is thinking what
he's thinking is marriage as a
foundational is is a pillar of a free
society
don't take the pillar away or the
society will collapse right so basically
you're going to
for saying this I think you might be a
liberal conservative well when they we
say is I'm a conservative because I'm a
liberal
I think liberals are not liberal anymore
the Liberals you know I call them left
this time your uncle a there yeah but
but that's what I call them that because
what are they liberal about within one
thing they're liberal about you know
that they're liberal about sex and drugs
but only because I think those things if
done irresponsibly enslave you you know
I mean what one of the things that I
believe in is you should have any sex
you want but don't ask me to pay for
what happens to you know that big drug
but don't ask then don't come to me and
say oh you know yet you have to pay for
my birth control you have to pay for my
my medical care you know that's the
point freedom comes with the
responsibility to take care of yourself
when things go disastrously wrong right
which they inevitably go for almost
everybody at also order liberals liberal
about I mean conservatives are the
liberal well I I mean I've been saying
this now all the time that defending my
liberal values is now becoming a
conservative position which I assure you
I don't like saying and it it's caused a
lot to be angry at me but say let me but
let's do the abortion thing for a bit so
are you fully right to life you know I I
am I would be satisfied I would be
satisfied here again just like with gay
marriage I feel the Supreme Court took
on Authority it doesn't have the Supreme
Court is pretending the Supreme Court
says you have the right in the
Constitution to have an abortion or
either right to gay marriage they're not
really giving you a right they're really
taking away from you the right to make
that decision within your state in your
community they're really stripping you
of of a right all the rights that are in
the Constitution negative rights you
know don't don't get in the way of free
speech don't get in the way of the right
to bear arms own infringe don't do you
know murders and yeah and others I think
that if things like don't right the
government things the government
shouldn't do but having said that I'm
sorry I've lost the track of the
original question was are you right to
life are you am i right yeah yeah I I
would be happy if roe v wade were taken
away so that we as a free people could
debate among ourselves what should be
done
I would then be making the argument to
be
right to life and I would be content
with the decision that the my neighbors
made my fellow members of the state made
but it does seem to me it does seem to
me that we live in time I mean this is
the biggest one of the biggest mistakes
people make an argument we live in time
a baby in a room left alone not touched
will become a full person it's the only
person in an abortion clinic who has no
vote no voice no way to tell its story
no way to make you weep for it seems to
me the government can protect that
person without infringing on our rights
yeah I mean this is one of the issues
that I find has gone so completely
haywire and I think on both sides
because if you listen to people on the
right they make it sound like people on
the left hate babies and if you listen
to people on the left they make it sound
like people on the right hate women and
I'm sure that in 90% of those cases
neither of those are true I grew so how
do you as a society then how do you take
something that someone holds as a real
moral principle and and negotiate
something that's fair like I would say I
think the woman has a right to choose
but I do believe that at some level at
least abortion is murder so maybe in the
first month you know this is where you
know I guess we're now we're talking
about real when does life start kind of
thing but like I would say in the first
month or two you could have an abortion
but clearly three weeks before
nine-month term pregnancy that's a
living viable thing and I've had I've
had people on the show saying you could
still have an abortion then which to me
is that's crazy
it's insane so how do you have that
discussion because we're not good at
that
right we're not good at oh there's some
legitimacy to both of your points no
we're really bad at it and TV just the
nature of television bears a certain
responsibility for that is just more
entertaining apparently they have to
people scream at each other and to have
two people discuss things as civilized
humans second half will get is
arm-wrestle yeah you know yeah and and
and it it's a problem because you are
talking about an absolute you're talking
about a human life
there's no way to partially kill
something there's no way to have a semi
abortion any more than you can be semi
pregnant you know it's the full monty no
matter what you do but I would be
satisfied if you know we
and if a state of state a locality
decided that you had the right to choose
for as you say a month somewhere before
the brain is fully engaged and then we
could at least preach because some
things have to be achieved through
preaching not through law we could at
least preach that you shouldn't do it
because we can win that argument I
always feel that the right there are
certain things that the right wants
legislated that need to be preached
instead I can sit with someone and
convince them especially if I build
structures for adoption and giving up
children and all that if especially if I
build those structures I might be able
to convince people and save lives that
way better than I can
legislating it and letting making people
go off to some other state and get an
abortion right so is that where the
right has failed in a certain way that
on one hand they're saying well we don't
want abortion which whether you agree
with their premise right with their idea
idea or not okay but at the same time
they also don't want to fund things that
might allow people to extricate
themselves of a pregnancy meaning they
don't want to fund you know certain
adoption clinics or whatever it is like
there's not enough of a safety net for
someone to go I could do this maybe and
and maybe I'll get some degree of help
well it's part of the failure that comes
with as it government expands
associations fail and that's one of the
problems that we're facing in this
country is there's not enough people
doing things independent of government
so everything the minute the minute a
church comes and says well give us some
faith base to aid you become an agent of
the government and those adoption
services don't need to be funded through
taxation they need to be funded through
individual effort and people do do that
and where they do it they're quite
successful so what would you say to my
friends on the left they would say well
the government didn't do it nobody would
do it and then that was it that you know
that's absurd I mean that's absurd the
world works very well without I mean you
know the the left is always talking
about the Enlightenment they know
nothing about the other and one of the
things that they learned in the
Enlightenment is that things work things
work there's an invisible hand that
makes things work without the government
telling you what to do that's kind of
one of the lessons of the Enlightenment
the less government there is the more
people grow the more people associate
the more people give charity the less
government charity is
the more charitable people are and and
so I would just say to them like stamp
you know you don't have to be in control
there really is the divide almost more
than right and left because right and
left you can argue things that really is
the divide between people who feel that
others need to be told what to do and
they're the ones to do it and people
like me who feel like go on you know go
on your way and don't call me trouble
yeah but you just want to leave other
people alone so you really think that
states rights in a way is the answer to
a lot of this right because then you're
giving the local people back their power
and if you don't like the local laws
take it to another state plus you get
the laboratory of democracy you get you
know gee that's working really well in
Georgia but this is working really well
in New York you know which is better and
why is it working well why is this one
failing I mean that's you know what we
have in Texas where you have this
incredible job engine and people should
be looking at saying what are they doing
that we should be doing I mean that's
yes of course we should be doing that
and and every time you bring this up of
course they bring up the the question of
black rights in the south and the voting
rights but that's an anomaly it was a
unique situation which people were being
cut out of the process by which states
laws were defined so that states rights
became invalid so that's a very very
small window where you had to fix that
but now that it's fixed you can't just
keep using it over and over again as an
excuse to take over more and more power
for the centralized government which
clearly does not know why should people
from Chicago know who go to Washington
know how to govern Texas it doesn't make
sense right it does make no sense so
everything that we've discussed so far
has virtually nothing to do with
anything that Trump ran on that's right
so that's where as a conservative again
he might be the president at this very
moment he might not be but what is the
future of the party it is there an
actual future or did this thing just
split to the point that it's irreparable
one of the things that is most
depressing about Donald Trump is that he
is in so many ways what the left always
said we were but
we weren't you know I mean he is this
nationalist as opposed to a patriot I'm
making a distinction there you know he
is this belligerent he is this kind of
no nothing who goes off half-cocked
about Mexicans and and this and that you
know he does all those things that we
were always supposed to have done while
we were sitting around I mean highly
intelligent highly educated
conversations about classical values and
they were yelling at us that we were
Donald Trump now we are you know and
that and that's a real problem and he's
going to take whatever happens he's
going to take a certain large portion of
the Republican Party with him
nothing like conservatism can survive
that's European conservatives right
don't like at all I mean the whole point
of American conservatism was it was
constitutional was based on small
government it was not based on America
right or wrong it was based on know
these principles because they're right
that's what it was based on I think
we're gonna have to reconstruct that
from the ground up I mean this is the
situation that we're facing and you can
run around as so many conservatives do
like the proverbial headless chicken
yeah I know saying the sky is falling
it's all over we're done or you can do
as Rudyard Kipling said and stoop to
build up the entire thing again with
your worn-out tools which means we have
to begin teaching people the very basic
premises that they have forgotten and
all these colleges where they're calling
for speech codes and all these colleges
where they shot you down on YouTube
where they take you off the air they
don't they don't remember they have
forgotten why you don't do that and we
have done a bad job of teaching them and
we have to start do you think that not
to put the two of us on such a high
pedestal but that people that exist in
our space that are doing this on on
youtube and itunes and all of the other
social channels that we actually do
represent in a weird way the last fight
against this monster because we now know
that I mean everything from WikiLeaks
again Hillary's probably present right
now but that everything between politics
and media has been so morphed and
they're sewing it together and there's
this like sliver of people that are out
there putting their views out whether we
agree or disagree
everything is irrelevant but that we
really are becoming like the last
bastion of people that are there to
fight for some level of freedom yes but
but there's always there's something
very hopeful about that it does remind
me very much of like when you're in the
desert and suddenly a drop of rain falls
life teams out of it you know for ten
minutes and then the rain has gone in
today yeah and so things like you know
ubers things like Airbnb that all the
app trading businesses are creating this
kind of vibrant economy that is sign it
kind of seeping through the cracks of
the regulation the over-regulation and
the over taxation and the you know
looming government political correctness
all these things are reaping to life as
as the overlords kind of fold in over us
what I'm concerned about with that what
I'm concerned about with that is it and
this everything that the left does
creates the opposite result of what they
want and political correctness which is
a cancer on the mind of man it has that
exact effect I mean I know you're
friendly with Milo you Napoles I admire
much of what he does in terms of media
sure but no it does not become
acceptable to become an anti-semite
simply because somebody's telling you
that it's unacceptable what the left
always does what the left always does is
they take this principle this small
principle of right like a little piece
of yeast and then they blow it up into
this and terrible wrong political
correctness is censorship it's
oppression it is 1984 but that doesn't
mean that the answer to it is to become
an uncivil and hateful right and that's
what I look I've said this to Milo
publicly and privately you know I think
there's a space for someone like him
because sometimes people there's a
certain amount of people that aren't
going to listen to Andrew clave and Dave
Rubin casually and calmly discuss some
ID like so sometimes you need someone
throwing out the bombs I think to wake
people up and and when I was at UCLA
with Milo I saw that that there were
people there that were liberals that
were waking up to some of this stuff but
they needed to hear it from someone like
Milo because he just got a certain
amount of awakening that said for
all of the people that all throughout
this campaign I heard saying well Trump
is the answer to political correctness
but this is this is insane yeah actually
that's right but this is what political
correctness does it gives a glamour to
bigotry you know I mean III I think
racism I think the entire notion of race
is kind of superstition and I think
racism is a mental illness but when you
say to somebody oh you know you said
that Obama's president and the world is
darkening you're a racist you know it
makes that one same you know and and
they started I think like well if you're
gonna tell me I can't if you're gonna
shoot me for you know a dog I might as
well be a wolf you know I'm really great
too and I think that that that's the
conversation that Trump created where I
kept saying you know he sounds like he's
being politically incorrect but he's
really just being vile there's a
difference yeah I'm politically
incorrect Milo can be politically
incorrect but but it's just vile to
denigrate and hate people for things
that don't mean very much at all what do
you make of the idea that over the past
couple months especially the last month
or so the election that there was a real
feeling of the whole the fixes in than
that that he I sense that people really
think that the underpinnings of what we
have going on here are really shaking
right now in a way that it never has
before that the whole legitimacy of our
government is shaking that that's a
dangerous place to be in it is a
dangerous place and the fix is in
I mean I have to say Trump Trump says
the fixes in because he's a narcissist
because he wants to create a little cult
around Trump he says it for all the
wrong reasons but the fix is in I mean
the IRS silences conservative groups
YouTube takes conservative videos off
the air the press is I mean look what
the press is doing to Donald Trump he
may deserve but they did it to Mitt
Romney who didn't deserve it at all you
know he was stalking women into binders
it was this horrible but you know the
the the press is always turning our
elections into a battle between good and
evil when what it really are is they are
a debate between policies what are
cleansed policies going to do what are
Trump's policies going to where Romney's
policies going to do what our bombers
policy is going to do Romney would have
won that election but they they
basically mess
with your mind and say oh well he puts
his dog on top of a car and that's
really important for the president
because some bang something's on our
time for a commercial you know I mean it
doesn't it
an ethical dog on the car yeah yeah and
I mean people feel rightly justly
manipulated censored and oppressed they
they are right in feeling that and in
their rage they did what people do look
one of the hardest things in life
hardest things in life is not being
reactionary I mean you meet people all
the time who hold the philosophies that
make no sense because their father held
to another philosophy and he was an Esso
being yeah and you know that's and
that's what people do with their whole
lives and we did that with Donald Trump
we were so angry justifiably angry I
would say anger is the devil's cocaine
because it feels so good and sometimes
it's justifiable but we still makes you
do stupid stuff yeah so you think going
forward that there could be an alliance
of sort of mainstream conservatives and
mainstream liberals and when I say
liberals I'm not talking about the left
is classical liberals like a classic
little bit I really do think there there
is going to be an avenue for the next
couple of years where people finally
this election got people it would be so
bonkers that people finally will go know
what so what I disagree with him on
three months for an abortion or this or
we disagree on whether gay marriage
should have been done by the states or
whatever it is but the basic tenets of
how I want to live in a society with
these people is okay and that maybe
there could be some new new middle there
can but people are going to have to
start thinking very very hard about the
foundational principles why we believe
what we believe it's not you know
whenever I hear a politician say as
Obama says endlessly that's not who we
are or you know our way of life I always
think I don't tell me about our way of
life our way of life is driving around
delay I don't care about our way of life
that can change you know and don't tell
me about who we are because who we are
is free which means the guy next to me
is kind of a jerk and I'm a wonderful
guy and all that that's freedom that's
what freedom is right you know it we
have got to start talking about
foundational principles and we've got to
stop playing down to the the passions of
the moment yeah that the conservatives
can Conservatives ever win that at any
time because you know
a guy like Paul Ryan who I disagree with
on some stuff I think that he's
basically trying to do what you're
laying out yeah he's trying to say
here's what the role of government
should be here's why I think it is all
that stuff but that doesn't get people
to show up to rallies and really bring
out the vote anymore it may be morally
right mm-hmm but that doesn't mean it it
can be successful in just the scheme of
how life seems to work these days well
it's a good question and it's a question
median I think I I believe in
trickle-down intelligence I believe in
the same way I believe in trickle-down
economics I believe that we have got an
Academy that has gone entirely wrong we
have got an Academy that is censorious
small-minded alleged ignorant and is
passing those values on to our young and
I think if we stop funding it so much if
we stop giving to our college because we
love the football team and stop saying
you know hey dude you know you cannot
take my child into a class on it you
can't give my child a degree in English
literature without teaching them
Shakespeare you cannot do that you know
that is not allowed because that that's
making it that's teaching em ignorance
is teaching them to be stupid you know
you cannot do that once we start doing
that you know maybe maybe look I
understand the media by nature
sensationalizes but it's kind of stuff
that we believe is sensational
the only revolutionary idea in
government anybody ever had was that
people should be free yes the only thing
that comes and it goes and in the
inertia the natural progress is toward
more slavery always so we're always
pushing the rock uphill we shouldn't let
that discourage us that's the game yeah
I've asked a bunch of my guests this
question and I've never gotten a
consistent answer on this one do you
think anyone's doing it better than
America for all of our flaws is there
any country that you look to and they
say you know they really have handled
Liberty right and the individual right
and their markets really work in a way
that I think they should and yet they're
also you know they're minorities are
still treated okay and the corporation's
haven't destroyed the little guys is
someone doing it better than us it's a
great question the reason it's almost
impossible to answer is because nobody
is doing it without us so so the the
English I lived in England for seven
years I love the English we got along
great but they preen themselves on the
ways that they're different from America
but I would
we save them hey you know you're living
in our garage the reason you're not
speaking Russian is because of us so you
don't have to pay for your military so
you put that money into something else
and then you make fun of us because
we're spending to protect you you know
and that is true of all of Europe
they're all sitting around going aren't
we aren't we lovely we've never fight we
never fight a war like those Ugly
Americans yeah because we protect them
so it's impossible to say the fact is
when you ask is anybody doing it better
nobody's doing it at all
without us every single human being who
is politically free on the face of the
earth every single one is politically
free because of something we did and
something we do and so and so you can't
really get rid of this engine this
protection this armament of democracy
and then say well he's doing it better
over there yeah you know I like I said I
lived in England I loved it it's in some
ways more civilized than it is here
because it doesn't have to produce the
kind of innovation the kind of money the
kind of size that it takes to defend
England we do that for right now so I
but I would imagine that some people
would hear you say that and even if they
grant you that there that the basic
premise of what you said is true they'd
still say that we have no right to be
all over the place or we have no right
to or not even know right what's the
point of us protecting all these
countries even Trump throughout the
campaign kept saying why are we
protecting Japan you know and all of
these things why not let your pan
protect itself or at least pay us for
those services which actually sounds
like they kind of do it was always very
confusing to me but but point being like
have we sort of gone beyond what we can
you know our own house isn't in order
have we just done too much well it's
possible obviously you can't as the
Roman Empire found out you know you
can't defend everybody if you can't
defend yourself and so yes you have to
be strong at home and we are very weak
our debt is a really really big problem
and and yet you can overextend what you
do but one of the beautiful things about
America that nobody points out is we
defend all these countries without
conquering them as it's never happened
before it's never happened in the
history of humankind that somebody has
expended the life blood and treasure
that we have in defense of other people
without taking them over
we give them a lot of shitty fast those
in England like a u dot you kill for
McDonald's french fries fair enough I
was down in El Salvador a couple years
ago and you know it's a true third-world
country they're burning their garbage
outside which at the first date kind of
smells good it smells like marshmallows
I think by day three you realize you're
telling nothing but I mean they had all
of our uh fast-food joints and I thought
I guess this is good but something also
didn't seem that great to me like you
guy that you would grant me that right
like at some level but I guess that's
how we change societies that's just the
first version of it yeah well we're a
fairly um what's the word I would use
were we're fairly uncouth people we are
a fairly uncouth people as the Romans
were fairly uncouth and when you look
back you know from all this distance at
the classical world there's some way in
which the Romans were just a vehicle for
spreading Greek culture Hellenic culture
throughout the world and maybe that's us
maybe we are here as a vehicle for
spreading European culture throughout
the world and we are uncouth and
belligerent and violent people all of
those things but we're the best we've
got and that's you know and it's worth
defending and it's worth defending them
as well it's worth freedom is a good
thing yeah so is that the irony
ultimately in our whole system is that
you know you could take a guy like
George W Bush who wanted to nation-build
and obviously Iraq certainly has not
worked out the way that he intended but
then we had eight years of Obama who
sort of was neither here nor there with
it at the same time then so we've
watched a rack slide backwards Syria for
all intents and purposes is not a
functioning nation-state and we're
basically watching a genocide over
400,000 people have died that we're big
we try to do good sometimes it works
sometimes it temporarily works and then
we take a step back and it gets worse
which is exactly what happened in Iraq
but we've gotten to the point where
we're so big and our intentions may be
good for with sometimes and sometimes
they aren't but it's just unwieldy at
this point and it almost doesn't matter
who's in charge I guess that's really my
question you know the reason I don't
agree with that is because I've seen
this before I've seen what's happening
now before with Jimmy Carter and the
left was just as the media was just as
prejudiced then but not cool
white as a pet you know they're not not
was obvious about it but they kept
saying oh well you know Carter made a
mess he just made a terrible terrible
mess and it was because the same reason
Obama's making a mess you know George W
Bush made a mess because he was he was
meant to be like Bill Clinton a holiday
president and the holiday came to an end
on his watch and that's really what
happened I mean you know there was this
wonderful explosion because of Ronald
Reagan because of Ronald Reagan because
he did such a good job solving the
problems of his time you know not all of
our time but of his time there was this
kind of holiday and Bill Clinton came
along and it didn't really matter what
he did or kind of what I didn't mess it
up too much and Newt Gingrich keeping
him in check they sort of did all the
stuff george w bush was set to be
exactly that kind of president he ran on
things like education and stuff like
this you know there's kind of minor
little things that he was going to do in
a time of peace the holiday came to an
end and he was called upon to be Winston
Churchill basically and he wasn't and he
was not that guy and and that's a shame
but Barack Obama has been a thoroughly
incompetent president for a different
reason it's because his philosophy is
wrong his philosophy does not describe
the world okay and so they used to say
that about Carter they say well nobody
can govern and then Reagan came along
and governed quite well thank you very
much he did a very very good job you
know he wasn't always right he might
have you know said some silly things
whatever he did a good job of bringing
the country back under control and
bringing the world to some extent back
under control
Obama is just everything Obama thinks is
true he's a false you know that does
make him a bad guy it just means he's
been trained in a philosophy that does
not describe the world accurately so
when he presses the red button and he
thinks the blue stick is going to fly
off this way instead the water squirts
in his face you know that that's right
so yes you can is a complex big country
but you can still govern it if your
philosophy describes the world realistic
so so would you say his philosophy you
know when he gave that Egypt speech
before he was president and then we had
this this redline fiasco in Syria I was
at the time I was on air at the Young
Turks I was every day saying we should
not be in Syria let other people clean
up this one but I did recognize that
once the red line was staked
out that if you do that and then don't
do your follow-through that you will the
ramifications will be horrendous right
and that is exactly what's happened here
so so I think basically what you're
saying is that his guiding principle was
sort of it was like a nice idea but in
practice you can't say things and not do
them because people the bad guys get
better and the good guys start worrying
he has this this phobia of colonialism
and so anytime we out act in the world
as what we are to some extent an
imperial power uh he becomes hysterical
and he you know you have a situation
where you know I have mixed feelings
about what happened in Iraq I think it
was a really poorly done even if it was
the right decision it was poorly done
but that war was won it was over and he
panicked and pulled out because he's got
this philosophy that wait I know the
comments section is going to be saying
but Bush signed the withdrawal of it
it's nonsense it would not have happened
that way you know under portion a they
would have had it they just need a few
forces there as many as they're there
now you know - right where which was me
going up there and they're going up and
now he's turned it into Vietnam it he
just he does not know how an economy
works he doesn't know how the world
works he has been trained in this
left-wing philosophy that simply doesn't
describe the machinery of the world and
and every time every time a a society
becomes socialist unless it has this
great big American capitalist America to
protect it in its socialism it 70 years
and it falls apart 70 years is the
lifespan of socialism and it just is
destroyed and so he was trained in this
idea that's just not true and he's so
arrogant and he too is a narcissist he
too has a narcissistic disorder I think
you know he doesn't change his mind when
the facts don't bear him out he just
says oh everything's going great and the
press backs them up because of their
racial pathology would you possibly have
a president that wouldn't have a
narcissistic personality it's a good
question I mean really really know it
sounds ridiculous but really I mean what
type of person yeah forgetting not just
the power that you would have not just
the desire for the power but I mean
you'd have to be so nice a just to go
through the
says which as we know can be quite
horrific yes I know I mean I think what
what has really happened with Obama is
there's this country has a racist a
racial pathology it is dealing with its
past in a very poor way it's like it's
like post-traumatic stress disorder the
fat the fact that this guy is an
incompetent and the first black
president is something that cannot break
through the narrative that the media
want to tell he is being incompetent
while black is just being incompetent
you know that's all it is and it's not a
knock on other black people who are
being confident it's not a knock on
anybody except the guys being in topic
he the reporting on him has been
insanely one-sided and it that because
what you say is true you need an
incredible ego to do what he's doing it
needs to be attacked every single day by
the press on mosques they should be
saying you're doing the wrong thing I
would you know the press was terribly
unfair to george w bush i was all for it
go ahead be on fair dome but be just as
in fair to brock obama they haven't been
anything like even as unfair as they
were they haven't been even as tough as
they were on Clint yeah it's funny I
during most of the Bush administration I
lived on the Upper West Side in New York
City the sense liberal liberal liberal
right and I remember at the end of the
Bush administration they'd have the you
know the Book Fairs outside right
outside by Zabar's alias tree and every
single book was about George Bush's the
devil George Bush is the devil every
single one and I remember thinking even
though I didn't think he I didn't he was
a great president but I didn't think it
was the devil everything and this is
actually kind of good because we have a
press and a media that's fighting
against the power and that's I think
really what you're saying here is that
we really lost that yeah you know these
last eight years and in a way that then
fed the Trump thing because then it was
easy for Trump to go see yet they they
all backed Obama now that Hillary as
you're absolutely right they were doing
exactly to Trump what they did to Mitt
Romney and the only difference is the
Trump reserves but at the same time
remember that you know it's what I call
the Che Guevara effect you know like if
you walk around wearing a t-shirt that
is Heinrich Himmler on it you know
somebody's gonna say like dude you know
but I walk around with Che Guevara who
is an evil mass murdering thug who
helped enslave a nation you know and
it's like oh wow che you can make a
movie about che and what a great guy he
was try
doing that with Himmler you know Suzanne
and I I feel the same thing as true of
Hillary Clinton that her evil is
normalized by the atmosphere by the
intellectual atmosphere that's created
by the press which Trump's elite you
know wickedness is obvious to everyone
you